[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
video game hangout here in San Francisco
California
every Wednesday 11 a.m. I'm your host
Mike McCarty here as always with Peter
downtown upside down frown brown reviews
editor you working on a few things you
played a Sega Genesis emulator is that
accurate to say or no but it's more of
like a it's a good NES classic type
system yes we'll get more into that
we've got semi full show today we got
lawbreakers persona 5 anime I'm sure
people will go off about that
specifically one person here on our cast
Mario plus ravaged Kingdom battle takoma
Wolfenstein 2 got a lot of stuff to talk
about today and as always we have a
giveaway I'll get to that later in the
show Shiva will put it up on our Twitter
page as always at the YouTube chat
twitch chat game spot chat up here stuff
everybody joining us feel free to hurl
some questions at us throughout the show
or comments snide remarks I'm here with
Rob handler as well hey what's up how's
it going going real great you played
Tacoma last night we'll talk more about
that yeah you did not review it though
no to Kali you reviewed it I did and
we'll talk more about that with you as
well mainly you I'm surprised he took
time out a dream daddy to play Tacoma
even though you had to review it yeah
well both are on my PC so I maybe played
some dreams you had it you know and
they're like a breakout window the top
radio I try to date everyone in Tacoma
doesn't work though that game yeah we
talk more about that game as always I
played Tacoma but uh cool yeah everybody
as always thanks for joining us I do a
few news things to get through as usual
to start to show off to one thing I'm
personally excited for resonable
revelations is coming to Xbox one and
ps4 which you already knew but the
release date is August 29th now which is
the same day as Mario plus Rabbids and
XCOM two's new expansion war the chosen
so I'm gonna have a tough day figuring
out what to play what is the what's
coming back for revelations everything
are they doing anything new to the game
because this has come out unlike good
question like five times yes
well also side note it is also coming to
switch in late 2017 so I might hold off
until that I don't know if there are any
new features I did not look into that
because right there's a survival mode or
mercenaries yes mercenaries mode which
they released with the 360 mode and they
made added it to the 3ds back in the day
but I'm just I don't know I'll play this
on every platform did you play these two
I reviewed the second one the coop one
right with berry Birkin makes his return
and foul-mouth Moira mm-hmm oh my god I
remember you having like some weird
issues of that where it was like they
were trying to make this little girl too
mature something they were trying just
so hard like they were trying to piece
together like vulgar phrases like if
they if they weren't human but they were
trying like what would humans say it
didn't know what they were doing I mean
the writers yeah I didn't actually
finish this one I played a little bit of
it but never finished yeah I do I do
that series with Mary Kish resin Knievel
and we are almost where we're like
getting through resin evil six but
depending on our time we're gonna go
back to like revelations code Veronica
and zero at some point so maybe we'll
try this on the switch this is just the
just the first revelations that's coming
out no one and two really yep two
switched in late this year but the the
release date for ps4 Xbox one is August
29th also Bioware Montreal the studio
behind Mass Effect Andromeda recently
announced it was merging with EA motive
which is working right now on
battlefront 2 but yeah if they said that
they are gonna be kind of moving them
over they didn't really give crazy
amount of reasons why I'm assuming maybe
they're just restructuring after
Andromeda this guy's fault this is our
behind scenes documentary about the
making of Andromeda disappointing game
for me personally I know a lot of people
liked it but you knows something new in
a series that everybody kind of holds
very dear near and dear to their hearts
but we might have more news coming out
from that I don't know like battlefront
2 we kind of know a lot about it that'll
be out in November later this year but
yeah so they're merging EA kind of
shuffling some stuff around and then
also Nintendo said the
yes classics will be available later
this month and they also said because of
the problems with demand for the NES
classic there should be their wording
not mine ample amounts of Ness classic
it'll be pre-orders this month it's not
gonna be available
yeah sorry September 29th pre-order to
Melville a tourism one month after the
release of XCOM 2 damn oh man I gotta
find time for the senesce classic put
aside ex-con after a month what are you
doing to me August 29th is shaping up to
be like a personal October 27th for me
October 27th is the day that uh Mario
Odyssey Wolfenstein two Assassin's Creed
origins stranger things season two and
there's some horror movie coming out the
27th it's a big day I got to figure out
what to do so it's gonna be it's gonna
be crazy cool and I'll announce the
giveaway later in the show we will get
to that Shiva will put up on Twitter
once you talk about it it's pretty cool
awesome Sega Genesis what's this thing
called into that yeah we jumped right
into it you did not like this hunk of
metal I did not like classic I did not
like this hunk of plastic there might be
some metal in there it's a his company
at games has been making very cheap Sega
Genesis consoles for years you've
probably seen them like in CVS or
Walgreens maybe at a gas station I don't
know they're widely available they're
super cheap and they're ready you
listened and they they've never really
been very very good
so beef jerky so the distinction for
this new one the Sega Genesis flashback
from at games is that it it's a first
one to support HDMI from the company and
it has 85 built-in games and it's coming
in the wake of the NES classics so like
people who maybe weren't aware of these
newish retro consoles are now sort of
like aware of them and are like oh I
want the Genesis version of the NES
classic it's it's a bit of a misleading
product like on the box it says 85 games
and it says Sega Genesis flashback so
you think oh it's 85 Genesis games it's
not it's it's 45 Genesis games and then
a mix of stuff that you didn't expect
almost 30 of those non Genesis games are
crap
things that were never released on a
sega system
outside of at games control their shovel
where they're no good this example of
one
Gianluca might pull up footage in a
second a game called spider okay act
about on the bomb cast yesterday where
it's a it's a wall and then there's a
cake on the table in front of the wall
and you have to move a cursor over
spiders and hit a button if you don't do
it fast enough so these are some of the
games I'm talking about fishtank live
plumbing contest mr. balls Thursday
nights nothing about star the packaging
is a bit misleading like it freezes on
the box that these are and new hit games
beyond this though there are some
functional problems with the system the
controller like every button you have to
hit twice before it actually activates
every time you turn on the system not
just Perkin not just like to activate
the controller but to activate the
individual button but the emulation of
some of the Genesis games is pretty poor
there's like framerate issues some sound
issues but Genesis sound hardware is
really difficult to replicate even
Sega's own systems after the first model
didn't use authentic hardware they use
sort of an approximation but this is
better here in terms of sound than 80
games previous stuff so the article I
put up said do not buy this thing
because I do think it's misleadingly
packaged I do think that at 80 games
it's not really doing their best effort
here that like I opened up the system
and I could see that like oh you can
power this thing over USB but they
decided not to route that port to the
back instead they make it use a power
brick so there's a lot of you know
little little issues here now eighty
games has said look this was a
pre-production unit we gave you we're
gonna send you a new one if you're
willing to reconsider it so I will be
looking at the what will be the final
production model of this in the coming
weeks can they fix the emulation issues
yes because this is the Android based
system and they can update software will
they that remains to be seen even if
they do fix that I would still be very
cautious about recommending this system
now my perspective is unique in that I
really care
about these games a lot and I spent a
lot of time like scrutinizing on video
game hardware and ways to play these
games on new equipment so for me I
noticed little issues very clearly if
you're just someone who hasn't played
Genesis games in a long time and you
just want to give it a shot maybe you
might like this but at 80 bucks it's not
exactly cheap and a lot of these games
are available on other systems like the
price of the senesce classic right yes
but the thing is Nintendo's attention to
detail is evident in the NES classic and
is wonderful and they do a really good
job of making those games play well you
know sound right look right
you know like 99.9 percent of the way
there and it's packed with good games
and it's not lying to you on the package
about what games you can expect inside
of yeah so you know if this thing is
ever like 30 bucks and you're a casual
Genesis fan who doesn't have access to
this stuff or a PC or a PlayStation 4 or
an Xbox one maybe consider it but if you
actually care about ol Genesis games and
you want them to play right and you want
to support a company that's doing things
the right way
just think twice mm-hmm but anyway keep
an eye out for an updated you know
review we'll see how that pans out once
they send me a replacement good yeah
that footage was stressing me out yeah
good action what's like changes they
would be giving like so I would imagine
it would be the controller in terms of
the button wake up stuff and the
dropping of frames in the emulation it's
hard for me to tell what hardware
they're using when I opened it up the
chip that my computer read when I
connected it over USB is different than
what I saw on the board so it almost
seems like they're using one chip to
spoof another chip that's out there so I
don't know if they're really using like
the right grade parts or what I'm not
positive about that but some things seem
a little weird it could be okay but you
know there's still a lot of issues like
even the fact that their controllers are
quite required triple-a batteries does
not come with any batteries which no one
ever has know and you need a secure you
need a tiny screwdriver to open the back
of the controllers does not come with a
screwdriver so no one ever has either so
you buy this thing for 80 bucks you're
then gonna pay tax on top of that you're
gonna have to buy batteries in a little
screwdriver you're gonna pay close to
$100 if you don't have batteries in a
screwdriver for this thing right
which sucks or a gas station near yes
does seem like like you mentioned
earlier on they're trying to ride this
wave of NES classics Ness classic but
you know st. prices sense classic but
you know we haven't got our hands on the
Super Nintendo yet but we haven't
purportedly that's gonna follow in the
wake of NES in terms of quality yeah and
like they've produced so many of these
systems by now they should understand
what their consumers want what they
don't like about their past stuff you
should not have to press a button twice
to activate it when you turn it on yeah
I mean this thing was rushed clearly and
the fact that they keep including these
games which have been in their previous
systems that the shitty ones is that
like they don't care that people don't
want this [ __ ] that they say why are you
telling me you have so many games when
it's not what's on the package that's an
issue damn yeah I mean what is the best
way to play all those other games now
like just Steam so on Steam you can go
there's like I forgot it's called like
the Sega Genesis library or collection
or whatever you buy individual games
that live within this hub and they're
super cheap there's always like a Steam
sale where you can like get all of them
for a really affordable price and they
have mod support so people can actually
modify these games and get official
support through Steam so they play well
they have features that they didn't have
before
and they're priced fairly I will say in
defense of the system it does have like
a rewind feature or like where you can
rewind six seconds or something like
that if you die yeah and they're a safe
state so that's kind of cool like
there's the potential there's the right
ingredients for this thing to be good
but it's like they over seasoned it with
a bunch of crap that they've mean to
grab from the cabinet mm-hmm
yeah if you wanna hear even more in
depth you can go read the full review on
GameSpot we don't have any like video
component to that do we wasn't worth the
time no well no I mean it was kind of
the thing that was sandwiched in we
don't usually make a big deal about
these projects and I kind of reviewed it
in my spare time but maybe we'll take a
look at it in video form for the final
version ya seen it has a video up if you
want to see some more the games being
played you can check that out as well
I went ham on it on giantbomb yesterday
I got pretty angry mm-hmm so if you
wanna hear me uncensored do you know
right now have more on sense
now no I don't care the venue's losses
might be mad if you go one sensor but I
wouldn't but sorry what I really quickly
as a Genesis kid I would like to shout
out
Gianluca sonic yeah yeah just because um
I have a lot of nostalgia for those
early sonic games I hate sonic games but
it's a good video
it's easy if you hate sonic games and
want to know where they went wrong from
the very start
go watch John Luke's go watch John
Luke's very good gentleman Richard Lee
both worked on this like 50 minute
history of Sonic pretty in-depth the
script was 17 pages yeah eight thousand
plus work yeah and I really Sonic the
Hedgehog 2 is like my childhood game I
like that's the game I played and tried
to master so I really liked watching it
as somebody who didn't really play a
Sonic game after that learning a lot
about like it's sort of like why this
series became a meme essentially yeah so
would recommend watching that
yeah and props to Richard too for
helping John Luke gather all that b-roll
like if there's one really neat thing to
see is like all the concept art and like
early footage and those commercials the
Sega commercial Bill Carver riot
inspirations yeah Bill Clinton's in this
video if there's like so much there so
it's relative at console Houghton the
YouTube chat was saying so I know that i
GN hates Sega and Sonic now we know
GameSpot feel the same that's just me I
don't like sonic sonic mania looks dope
okay I am so excited for Sonic me
honestly yeah I think one of the really
Kyle just I'm gonna do this really
quickly the the coolest thing that John
Luke touches on it's like for the early
Sonic games is what made it so
compelling is a lot of the the structure
of levels was different from platformers
at the time so they're very lane based
vertically with like the higher lanes
giving you better rewards and falling
doesn't necessarily mean failure just
means you don't get you know the shield
or whatever it is and that's the kind of
thing I loved as a kid was just figuring
the best route to take so yeah it was
just kind of cool seeing the thought
process or hearing about the thought
process behind those design design
design decisions hard to say and this is
how sonic should run not like the way it
ran in the footage we on that at games
thing sorry what is the official I still
gonna with the official you don't know
at games is it an actual like at games
but do you know those two letters 80 but
it's like internal capped so I don't
yeah yeah who's playing that yeah that's
specifically from a part where he's
talking about dying okay yeah very
convenient could cover up Kali
alright cool we also played the
lawbreakers beta and by that I think I
mean I played the lawbreakers beta did
you guys get the chance I know I tried
to care about it and I just don't yet
okay I was like that before I played
this I played the Alpha they had a few
months ago there's only three classes
available I forget what they I think it
was enforcer tighten and Wraith I don't
know but I now they end the assassin but
they added the like all now there's all
eight classes and they also have the
gunslinger now which is a really cool
class in one hand they have a burst
pistol on the other hand they have like
a charge up revolver nice it's nothing
completely novel but it's still what I
like about the game the more play is
that it's blending kind of the arena
fast-paced shooting aspects of like a
quake with the hero shooter aspects of
overwatching yes like use your weapons
so I propel you yeah and there's zero-g
areas like this when why not from bosky
games of Cliff Bleszinski Gears of War
Unreal Tournament kind of Fame but the
more I play it the more I'm excited for
it we actually I don't want to go too in
depth because it comes out very soon
August 8th next Tuesday if I'm not
mistaken so miguel concepción will be
reviewing that i think well we're
getting that just this game specifically
at the same time as anyone watching
right now we'll be playing that
alongside the main release so the review
won't be up right away before on or on
october 8th but i'm excited for this
game I want to play it you know all the
maps have that zero-g kind of
verticality to him yeah I think that a
lot of them do
yeah it's a lot of it's the center zone
or just uh I think it changes sometimes
it's pretty cool it's it's kind of like
what I wanted infinite warfare to do
with their maps at the zero D in outer
space
for that matter yeah I'm definitely
going to play it when it comes out I
just yeah I'm not like fully sold I
loved
I mean quake was one of the first games
I ever played so hopefully I end up
enjoying this he just hasn't like
grabbed me for some reason it can be
tough I it's one of those games where I
it kind of makes me anxious to play on a
controller because it seems so designed
for a mouse and keyboard because of the
verticality yeah I mean even right now
they're just getting shot from above
like it's making me feel so weird like
knowing I don't know even I'd crank a
sensitivity up a ton but uh cuz over
watch I can play on consoles but even
this game is still so slow you guys are
just talking about like you know rocket
jumps and propelling yourself like
that's and I think there is a quick look
like behind you button isn't that right
probably something like that but you
know that's very much like a mouse and
keyboard thing right like it's yes
sensory sensitivity yeah so really this
is August 8th for ps4 Xbox one PC will
have our like probably a review and
progress up I would imagine maybe or we
just might wait and who knows I don't
know Pete reviews that are do you do you
guys have a plan yet we shall see cool
all right so that is all I want to talk
about for lawbreakers considering the
game releases very soon talk about that
more next week I'm sure and Atlas
dropped a news deus on all of us as I
like to say so first of all let's get
this over with
persona 5 has an anime coming out I'm
just kidding I don't not an anime fan
but it's a1 studios anyone pictures
anyone pictures which you might know
from they make they've made a lot of
popular enemies so fairytale sort out
online and then a couple that are you
know smaller but considered to be really
good on Ohana is one of those the flower
I saw that day and then they made erased
which I liked up until the very very end
so they also did the persona 4 golden
animation was it done persona before was
that very close to the persona 4
storyline I haven't watched it I from my
understanding it's a
a pretty faithful adaptation even if it
doesn't you know like go beat by beat
the story I think they do a good job
with that it's a lot of like game to
anime is gonna be like that but yeah I'm
very excited I mean like the the
animation in this is really cool so I'm
really excited to see what they do with
it
I like I've liked a ones stuff so there
are some pretty gorgeous anime cutscenes
in the game yeah in with yeah I really
like except for the Beach one that one
was weird
yeah that was one small part of Alice's
announcements so that will be leading
into persona through really quickly we
don't have confirmed for the u.s. or for
the West it's to air in Japan in 2018 so
we'll see about the licensing later okay
and then they also announced persona 3
dancing Moon Knight and persona 5
dancing star Knight if you what was what
was persona 4 dancing all night yes yeah
yeah dance all night anymore they just
have to dance for some celestial being
of the night it's really weird seeing
Makoto wearing like colors I don't know
that I like it she's my favorite persona
5 character that's what this is this is
dancing Moon Knight persona 3 right here
I don't know persona 3 characters all
they went 5 is my only persona I played
but yeah someone explain these dancing
games to bringing games well ok they're
rhythm games and a lot of people who get
really attached to the characters like
here we go 3 likes a definitive version
and fans want to remake well this is not
that seeing high res models of the
persona 3 cast dot-dot-dot along with
own recreations of environments gives
hope for a full persona 3 HD remake ok
so that contextualizes a lot of things
although he was underrated I'm glad it's
getting a follow on right person the key
to being the percent of 5 themes yes
dungeon crawler where you have to admit
it's sort of like Etrian Odyssey yes
yeah they also announced persona q 2 for
3ds which is like you were saying the
spin-off focused on dungeon crawling
persona q
the labyrinth did a similar thing with
three and forecasts yes so sorry for
those who were just like listening to
this after the fact that was our
producer John Luke chiming in he's a big
persona fan he did the history of
persona speaking of John Luke in history
of yeah it's a basically persona
spin-off day mm-hmm announcements which
itself has already spent off that's
exactly Shin Megami Tensei I was joking
see that's that's okay there's Makoto
and her colorful shoes I dig her outfit
I don't it doesn't seem like pakodi
makoto to me and she was my favorite
character I'm not super saying right now
is exactly why people like these rhythm
games because if you can decide whether
an outfit is fits her personality that
means you're totally invested in these
characters and that's why people like
these spin off so much in control of
them yeah dancing also Sapor makoto to
me there is a fantastic persona 4
dancing all night
remix thing with next episode and the
your little cousin I forget her name
right now and she does it's it's a good
video I like it a lot yeah that's Makoto
on the Left goob
doesn't look like or does it that's not
cool
who is it holy God I gotta move on from
this I don't I'm oh [ __ ]
sweet so that's I got that completely
wrong show so much I know about Makoto
cool so we are is there anything else
tough to say about this there's a lot of
things we just kind of cover quickly Rob
you say you seem to be a chatterbox
right now I don't really know persona so
or anime or dancing rhythm games flusher
watched huh what's the last name to me
you saw the last anime I saw Castlevania
that's not that's not animate correct
did you watch Dragon Ball anything no am
I gonna get like attacked
I would say I don't know I think Akira
was something I finally got around to
that's not anime just kidding [ __ ]
cool Akira it goes in the shell I've
seen that yeah that's about it yeah same
here
I don't know Pokemon that's anime okay
did you watch Pokemon yeah yeah Kali you
recently played Mario Plus Rabbids king
of battle you know Cruz right pass let's
move on
Mario Plus Rabbids Kingdom battle you
Jake and over in the UK
Oscar dais all played it recently I'm
super excited by this game
Oscar dais you know why because it looks
like we did a couple questions later on
we have a question about this game that
I will throw at you but first off what's
it like to finally get your hands on
this after we saw it at e3 um I was
surprised by it
Oscar wrote a really good piece about
just how difficult it was and I think
that's the biggest thing is nobody
really expected it to be as to have the
strategic depth that that it does from
what we played played about three hours
I do think the difficulty was a product
of we didn't get to experience any
tutorial stuff we didn't really get to
learn the systems one of the levels we
played was like 20 hours into the game
that surprised me so I was like this
game is 20 hours long and it wasn't even
the last level so I was like this game
is more than 20 hours long but there is
a lot of depth to the team composition
and characters so the Rabbids characters
are a little bit more they hang back a
little bit more they have like utility
abilities peach has really really good
like healing jump and a lot of its
positional so that's peach not like
rabid peach actual Princess Peach yeah
do they have other names and is it just
rapid peach literally rabid Luigi rabid
you know whoever the only character we
didn't have access to for some reason
was
Yoshii um heresy yeah but you got looks
like but yes you can see here you can
jump off of another character but and we
saw that before but the the cool thing
about that is turn order and like
figuring out which characters you want
to move first is a really big deal and
then we played some co-op which was a
lot of communication actually because
you can kind of you can either say I'm
gonna move my two characters first or
you should we should all move and then
I'll move peach and jump on you and
that'll heal everybody um and that was
just like the surface level stuff that
we were getting from figuring this game
out and then when we get into the harder
levels it was very much like you have
there was so much depth to it we all
pretty much everybody I talked to who
played a Jason dan and Nate in the
Australian office play as well we just
got our asses kicked by this game like
we were we were not doing well in a good
way it was very much like okay I can't
wait to actually get my hands on this
game not in a preview environment
because I really need to learn I need to
this is the kind of game I need to play
through in order and really work hard to
understand and work on systems like one
by one right yeah like there was a point
where they were showing us like before
we went into the the second level we got
to play with like the spooky like boo
themed castle level and the before we
like start playing it they showed us
examples of chain combos we could do and
it was just all this stuff for it was
like oh and Luigi like rabid Luigi has
this ability that pushes things back and
if you do that you have access to this
and and we were all like what is
happening like we haven't even looked at
the skill trees yet so there's just so
much going on and I was really really
surprised and I can't wait to actually
experience it for myself when I was
playing this level you can't this is the
spooky boo level the one of the devs was
like helping me figure out what to do
because I got crushed like an absolutely
destroyed that's what's super appealing
to me also using kind of the Mario level
design tropes in this kind of tactical
game yes yeah and that's part of the
positioning so going through a pipe gets
you like you have and you can upgrade
this in this
tree but you can go like three to five
steps out of the pipe and then if you
have another character who's there you
can then jump off of that character and
get up on this platform and the the
actual the goal was like right behind
that platform but I couldn't get up to
it because I didn't have a second
character there and there's just like
that jump and pipe combination mastering
that I think is gonna be really really
interesting and make these battles
really exciting I'm really curious how
yeah how the overall structure work is
there an actual I mean there must be a
strategy layer between levels when
you're actually managing upgrades and
inventory did you get to see that yes we
got to you see the full skill skill tree
Oscar broke that out and you can see
that on GameSpot now and he also broke
out all the characters so if you're
curious more about the in-depth stuff in
menu stuff that's all on GameSpot but
yeah the the skill tree management was
really interesting because not only do
you have to figure out what would be
most useful excuse me on that character
you have to figure out what would be
good in combination with the other
characters you have in which characters
you want to bring into each battle um
there was just a lot I mean three hours
I felt like I barely wrapped my head
around it mm-hmm it seems also like I'm
really excited for the precedent this
might set for more tactical RPGs on the
switch just that seems really
well-suited for the handheld model right
like I mean you're only seeing a limited
part of the map at a time anyway and
obviously gonna be scrolling through no
matter what platform you're playing it
on it seems awesome for the switch
absolutely did you get a chance to play
handheld no no not even a pro controller
the whatever the charging grip is we
were playing with that and then I think
I think this is yeah this is my footage
where it's like trying to figure out
where to play speech and she's just like
there's so much going on and there I I
should mention there's two different
kinds of battles we played besides the a
boss section there's like reaching a
goal and there's defeating all of the
enemies on the field or like a certain
number of enemies
that's peaches healing jump that you saw
and so that changes your strategy too
based on which what your goal is
obviously which is how strategy games
work yeah it's just I need more time
with it I feel like I still don't
understand there's like co-op like
special levels right mm-hmm did you any
mention of PvP no we didn't I didn't
hear anything about that co-op was cool
though I I should emphasize like it was
hard it was almost harder even the level
didn't seem as hard um you need to
communicate a lot for I would assume
yeah how long did you get to play co-op
of those three hours um we played for
think like 45 minutes co-op I think okay
and those will be special missions you
do unlock throughout like a gun normal
campaign or this is it's a separate mode
that's I that's not very clear
I think it's separate but I'm not sure
they had like save files that we went
into so I didn't get to see really like
the unlock process too much yeah
this is will come as a surprise to
nobody but even like seeing more of this
gameplay it does remind me like having
separate goals that kind of throw you
off your normal strategy isn't very it's
an ex-con thing to do and I know that
ex-cons not the first one to do
turn-based tactical strategy but I am
really excited for this because I would
like to see how other games kind of take
that formula Lloyd Christmas on Twitter
was asking is this more than just an
ex-con clone and it seems fair to say
that it is yeah I think they really like
one of the things I mean you brought
this up just using like the Mario game
tropes I think they really embraced the
unique things about each character and
the things that you would recognize so
of course peach is going to have a
healing ability Luigi has a sniper rifle
which is pretty cool but I think like
going into the skill tree and really
seeing how the characters interact with
each other and like which abilities in
combination work well I think they
really embrace like the the Mario
I guess universe the Mushroom Kingdom so
I like that they really made it they
made it Mario right like it's it's not
just a a Mario skin on a strategy game
it's still fascinating to me that
somehow Ubisoft a Nintendo teamed up to
do this right I don't get it I love it I
will say still not sold on the rabbits I
just say I only brought one with me I
was like I'm bringing peach she's my
girl we just like Opie you gotta have
peach I'm worried this is like a
precursor to a means strategy game to a
what what are rabbits
they're the minions they're a video game
they are they're just I said
rabid Yoshi and then thought about I was
like yeah like an actual rabbit rabies
effects millions of toadstools every
year so PSA probably watching those my
dumb joke for the segment cool anything
else touch on with that game oh yeah
actually one thing that I was talking to
Oscar about is Oscar was saying like
this made him like really want to have
peach around and I've always been a
peach supporter and so I was very happy
to hear that I think it's just it's nice
to see peach like still being like her
princess you know character but being
really useful on the team and while
you're worrying it no no later I the
only there was a character thing have
everybody and there's a great out one
and it was clearly Yoshi and unlocked in
yo I'm very I love peach and so that's
my little shout out for peach maybe
they're like the bad guys on the rabbit
side somehow they appear later on that
would most traders or you play bonuses
mini-boss I have to imagine do something
I would love I would love to see some
some good waluigi memes for sure so
that'll be out August 29th we have much
more stuff on the site if you wanna go
read further into it we have a few
videos and yeah like Oscar wrote
something out did our Australia team
play as well yep
a little strategy they did like five
things we learned yeah yeah yeah I
actually before we close out one quick
thing is uh I'm not I'm nervous for kids
trying to play this game honestly I kept
thinking about that like I can't imagine
me as a kid being like I'm gonna play
the new Mario thing and then or parent
buying it it's like like knowing like if
my little brother tried to play this
when he was like a kid still like he
would have thrown the console really
good implementing like safety nets where
you die a few times it's like do you
want to be invincible for the rest of
this level so there isn't I will say
there is an easy mode which I did not
play but it does make things simpler I
can imagine yeah so I think that's there
for kids but like I don't know if you're
a kid maybe you don't I think like I
didn't encounter anything where the game
was like do you want to change the
difficulty like if a kid didn't find
that that would be my only concern but I
mean they do have those safeguards but
maybe I'm not super into maybe I don't
have the clearest understanding of how
the development is working isn't this me
like a Ubisoft developed game yeah but
Nintendo has oversight they would tell
them maybe to like yeah I wouldn't give
them mario without no control everything
I'm sure the easy mode was a Nintendo
thing like hey gotta make this for
everybody and like you gotta imagine all
the character mannerisms and things yeah
signing off and like just to show how
much power they have over at Miyamoto
came out with a gun to a smoke show
during the press conference at e3 I hate
I hate that rabid peach is just taking
selfies I hate it I don't want her to
stop and the rabbits are like shaking
there there's like like the the title
screen like before you were like press
any button to continue
has just a rabid farting I'm like just
let me play the guy I want to see any
farts or hear any verse I'm into it
personally
cool so Mario Plus Rapids August 29th
for Nintendo swish I'm really excited
for that
but a game that just came out today well
last night technically takoma the
sophomore effort if you will from
Fulbright now used to be the Fulbright
company when they make gone home in 2013
but your review is up and you know like
a few people in the office have played
it it sounds like we all agree the
characterization is fantastic maybe some
broad strokes and the overall story
didn't exactly hit but from what you've
said it's pretty memorable absolutely I
think it's memorable I would recommend
playing it I just wanted more of a
payoff from it than I got and I think
that's to its credit almost like I was
so invested in these characters that
when it ended I was kind of like no but
wait there has to be something more to
this and I actually did I was testing
the Xbox one version yesterday to make
sure everything was working and all good
to go for the review and I had like a
revelation like playing the beginning
and I was like oh that's what that was
but even that wasn't enough and I still
think that they have these fantastic you
know this fantastic attention to detail
you go into one character's room she has
a copy of the bell jar her cat's name is
Margaret cat wood I'm like okay well I
know who you are now you the trash tells
a story like there's there's so much
attention to detail in the environment
and the bigger picture stuff in this
story I think didn't necessarily get
that same foundation and that's where
the payoff kind of missed the mark for
me yeah um
where I think they built this really
interesting world there's this really
this really fantastic picture of like
just a horrible version of capitalism
where like your loyalty to a company
it's an actual currency is current the
year twenty eighty eight contextualise
yeah and for people who don't know what
the gameplay is like it's you're seeing
pretty much what it is now and I think
it's one of those things that plays
better than it looks for some people but
you kind of follow people around there's
actually style of theater that's like
this or you can follow actors around and
that's what this reminded me of you
follow you know one conversation and
then
you know a lot of the crew will kind of
group up in this sort of sequence and so
I just rewound and followed different
people and got the full picture and it's
actually a really cool it I think I
really think it just doesn't sound as
good to people who aren't really into
that kind of game but it is gamified a
little bit where you're checking
people's desktops and you have to get a
checkmark on everybody's to kind of
complete that recording and the desktops
are fascinating I mean like 15 minutes
in the game you see like a body pillow
thing and I was like ah that's Nina
Freeman stamp on this game sibel yeah
and there's a little Easter eggs like
Sybil as in this and I've liked Nina's
games in the past so it's kind of cool
to see those things as somebody who's
played all of like played gone home and
play Nina's games yeah it's really it's
really well done I like that that style
of characterization yeah as an evolution
of what they did we've gone home they
weren't the first you know like walking
simulator which started as a derogatory
phrase but now it was later embraced by
people ironically but DRS turn 2012
kind of did that with a Chinese room and
Dan pinch bunk to pitch back who later
worked on amnesia too but I you know
like you're walking through you're
getting contextual details environmental
storytelling gone home I think it worked
and there was that kind of voyeurism you
get by going through people's Diaries
and their letters and their things in
their trash and I think that worked
because it was such a short game I like
that they kind of have evolved that like
you were saying in these augmented
reality scenes it's a different kind of
voyeurism I think I described as like a
interactive Rashomon where you can kind
of see them all convene and then go off
into their separate rooms when they go
to have these incidental conversations
you get character relationships like
this you have Natalie and Roberta if I'm
not mistaken but we won't spoil too much
about characters there's Odin the
station AI and that plays it into the
story as well because you are your
character
Amy Ferrier Ferrier I'm not sure if it's
like French farriers a clever play on
her role in the game if you really think
yeah that's true well she's a
communication specialist yeah your sense
of recover the the like data logs of a
ship right which are in AR form often
yes
what happened and this is another thing
that Fulbright does really well is
giving just impressive depth to
characters who aren't even actually
there I mean like these characters don't
have faces but I was really connected to
them and that's something that gone home
did as well I mean you don't even have
the outlines of people in that game
you're listening to your sister right
yeah you get like family portraits and
yes you see pictures of her and I mean
you see pictures of their faces too in
this through there like im's and stuff
you see their profile pictures but I
just think it's really impressive that
they're able to give such you know just
to have that fantastic characterization
in an unconventional way and I wish that
that had extended to the stuff with Odin
and AI I think could have been hit a
little harder for sure and you feel
about the linearity of the game because
despite it being open-ended to the
degree that you can explore freely mhm
it's pretty clear about what it wants
you to do it's extremely linear and I
think and that works i I'm not sure I
think it would've been too complicated
to to make it open-ended because you get
parts of the story that wouldn't make
sense without the foundation like I
think there's obviously purpose in that
linearity and it actually didn't bother
me too much because I was able to kind
of wander around the ship and pick
through people's trash and like listen
to the radio when no one was in the room
and like I think there's enough
flexibility that it didn't bug me
personally it didn't I wouldn't say that
it bothered me but I think maybe was
underutilized
as a like so one of the things you do
when you follow people away from their
conversations and you see them like on
their own is they might be putting a
code into a door right so the final
section of the game is you're doing
something different than you were doing
before and for me the game was very
clear about where to go and it was like
it would have been nice if I could've
like used a little bit more of my
experience as an investigator on the
ship to get to that point I almost felt
like it was it was given to me way too
easily that yeah that I agree with I
think even the so to compare it to pray
even like I think before the game came
out somebody joked to me that it was
like pray without a gun and I think like
you go in without that stress that you
haven't pray and you can kind of just
explore at your own leisure which I like
and you even note like that one of the
first things your AI on your ship tells
you is that the crews been evacuated so
it's not even like oh my god everybody's
dead it's very relaxed and the way
you're exploring and I liked that
but finding codes it's like a is is part
of it to access certain things but it's
not necessarily difficult to do that and
I agree that like toward the end when
it's like like shit's getting real I
would have liked to have had to dig a
little deeper but I did have to dig to
learn things about people so I guess
it's like an it's a opportunity cost
kind of thing so I can dig through
literally dig through somebody's trash
find like empty wine pouches and be like
oh they're having a rough day and
there's that aspect of extrapolating
information that way that's not spelled
out for you whereas the more
straightforward gamey stuff was more
spelled out so there's just I think it's
a trade-off
yeah like hearing the linear aspects
like there was one thing that kind of
bothered not bother me but like they're
like kind of add-on to what Peter was
saying was it on the bottom HUD it
straight up kind of gives you story
beats and and kind of pushes you to
check those off so they become it shows
it shows little markers on the timeline
when people open their and you and you
have to access those to progress the
story or seemingly wait forever for this
little countdown timer thing to move
yeah but when you do things that like
moves faster it's not there yeah I think
there's so there's an achievement for
seeing every recording and accessing
every desktop so I you can complete the
game without getting all those
checkmarks and I but I think you'd be
missing out on a lot of things if you
didn't do that but I agree that it's
kind of like oh I should probably go to
this person's conversation now cuz they
just pulled up their desktop yeah like I
mean what's once I got that real I mean
I caught it later I noticed it was there
but once I understood the rewind aspect
of it like and that was very needed you
know you're an investigator really like
I should I know it's it's like I didn't
need the the hand-holding like I'm of
course because the voice acting is so
strong and like characters like off the
bat I was like oh I want to see every
bit of like the
you know once you get that taste of like
you know two people are having a
conversation and then this first one can
go over here and be like god I hate that
guy yeah yeah like once that happened it
like just totally like like pushes you
to see every corner and it this the feel
in the rule of the rewind itself is so
great like yeah that was real fun to
just like rewind back forth or like oh
what did he say like that was a little
vague we were one that again it's like
instant gratification yeah once I saw
that I was like oh okay well now I'm
going to see it every time I go into a
new area I'm just gonna I don't know
what's what's my play gonna be from
different from yours is that I did two
before one and you did one like it's all
I don't know yeah I think yeah that is
the thing I was when I was writing the
review I initially had like oh the first
recording you see is this and then I
realized that it's one of two that you
could see for first but I like there's
clear markers in the level design that's
like party this way and so I think most
people would go that way first and so I
think I mean it's similar to gone home
like if we all played gone home we got
the same story but maybe it meant
something different to us and I sure
that's the thing with this kind of
interactive storytelling and like
environmental storytelling so there's a
lot I liked about it I just it didn't
Wow me the way that gone home did and
like gone home I still think about on a
regular basis and what that game meant
to me and not to say that this isn't
yeah I mean I gave it a set I it's a
good game right like it's I I there's a
lot to like about it I just wanted a
little bit more from it so I haven't
finished it I'm about from what you said
Pete like three quarters of the way
through or so maybe oh I do agree that
so it's set up like a series of scenes
and you mentioned like things like Sleep
No More in New York City which I've been
to which are really cool it's like an
interactive play where you get to walk
around and kind of hang out with people
it's almost like it's it's not the same
thing it's not horror but it's like a
haunted house right sits interactive
kind of play thing I didn't I'm not
finding the game to be all that linear
in the sense that I go into a scene and
I see this guy walk from over here and
then I see these two having a
conversation and then maybe they started
here so it's linear in the sense that
the scenes themselves apart from like
where you could choose between two
scenes at one part that I've seen so far
I do agree that the overall
sure the game is linear but I found the
scenes to be really satisfying in that
those scenes themselves I I'm fairly
certain that I probably saw them play
out very differently than you did so
well there was a time line or whether it
was seeing this player this precarity
playing a really kind of like melancholy
song on her guitar in her room but then
going back and then like I do wish like
you said Rob that those markers on the
timeline weren't there that might I felt
like while I was trying to listen in on
this person or really get a sense of
this character I saw those and that
almost seemed like an objective marker
today they are object you have to cue
right right sure yeah and so in
completing and progressing through the
game it's very linear but I think it is
maybe it was the sense of the frame of
mind I went into it I kind of I did see
those and I knew liked it once we
figured out how those we kind of saw in
the gameplay earlier when the
protagonist kind of unfold this notebook
and puts it or this like this iPad kind
of thing puts in the wall it starts
downloading the AR data like you said
that it goes like 0.1% every five
minutes yeah a few so basically you
can't move until to the next section of
the game until that download is complete
yeah and that either happens very very
very slowly over time or as you access
desktops yeah because you can't see it
and so then you go back it so we're done
yeah yeah although in my replay I didn't
access every desktop but it did give me
the like done mm-hmm like a hundred
percent there yeah it was because I'd
done the main scenes or something
because sometimes like you go to
somebody's private quarters and it's not
like necessarily an important scene but
they do pull up their desktop oh oh yeah
sure I just amended the ones that are on
the time yeah the main ones yeah
oh yeah I like I said structurally I
agree with you I think it is a linear
game when you look at it like in broad
strokes and how you actually progress
through it but I almost think I'd be
overwhelmed if I had the entire space
station and all these scenes to play out
at once they'll be very cool and I'd be
curious to see how that would work but I
think it's structured enough like I said
I don't like those objective markers on
the timeline but wait until you finish
it because sure I haven't been I feel
like the the payoff that it goes for is
hindered by like I said the sort of
spoon-feeding linearity okay it's very
explicit in terms of what it wants you
to do and there's only one way you can
do it okay interesting because where I'm
at right now it doesn't feel like that
but again I'm
part I think I just kind of learned what
the overall conflict is outside of the
character relationships curious to see
where that goes
from what you say it doesn't really pay
off in your opinion I'm I'm curious to
see right but like I that's not I don't
think that's why any of us were really
excited for this game right or maybe it
was that's not that's actually not
actually well I wasn't but I get what
I'd have to finish it and see what you
mean because yeah I mean the linearity
thing isn't like a huge knock against it
that's not what I'm implying but I think
it that was one of the things where I
felt like I was being ushered through
the whole thing rather than like I did
take time to like look in people's
lockers and do stuff like that and right
but even then it was like three hours
and I was done with the game and it was
like okay crap I felt like I was
investing myself and then that
investment was sort of just like halted
it that's exactly how I felt I mean so I
think through that linearity for the
like the outside conflict outside of the
station like the more political aspect
of this it's interesting but the stuff
that you are I guess
nuts I wouldn't say spoon-fed I think
that's too harsh but like the things
that you're given don't build up enough
for the payoff it's going for I think
and when I did that rooting around and
tried to do like the oh I'm gonna find
the things that aren't given to me there
wasn't enough there and like that was my
biggest problem I think I spent like
twice as much time I don't know how
Peter was like I'm capturing and then
like two hours later he was done with
the game and I was like oh my god this
game took me like five and a half I mean
so you're doing things like you know we
saw at the party there's a what's name
of the part of you obsolescence party
letters are all like mixed up and like
some are falling and you went and you
put them back in order and it was like
really yeah like I for some reason when
I saw that I didn't even think about go
can I fix this
yeah but when I saw someone's personal
effects that's when I would look so I
looked at that stuff yeah I didn't do
the like the surge of environmental
things that didn't seem to have any
connection yeah maybe that's why I
finished it yeah it's really interesting
in and you brought a good point to or
like I'm pretty sure you were words
where it's like you know the Agony's
objective markers like to what extent
like you know it's given to you and and
maybe that is a fact
your exploration right if like I I go
into a room and I don't initially
trigger that final objective then I'll
move out of the room but on the flip
like I almost wonder like it's
interesting like I almost wonder if
maybe just a lighter form of those I
don't know what it like they roll out
later the objectives were it's like hey
all right you seem to be lost
maybe this area I don't know how you why
else you could do it but I I could see
the counter of like maybe just like
getting exhausted just looking forever
like it's it there is a balance there
right like I
there were times where I was like oh I
you know I kind of do want to just not
you know speedrun it but right kind of
just get to the bigger meat of it
because I I had no when I saw like the
you know like the encrypted like files
on their desktops everything that like
that once I saw like I couldn't access
some of those party was like I I have to
look in every cranny like I'm not gonna
get that and so I kind of dismissed that
whole aspect and did kind of want to to
get through it quicker and yeah and have
the more walking simulator time like
it's a it's a balance for sure and it's
you know the fact of the things are laid
out it makes sense in the context of why
you're there and how you're doing the
things you're doing so at least that's
you know taken care of right I also
think that it gives you enough reason
right away to want to look for those
things if like if you're already
inclined to that like I think the you're
alone on this station but you're not
alone like I think that dynamic is so
cool and that's what drew me initially
so having those objectives feels almost
like oh no it's okay I was already going
to look for those things like but like I
said my main thing with the game was it
just didn't it didn't have that payoff
and I think a lot of that was paying a
lot of attention to characters and then
kind of letting some stuff rest too far
in the background and this is just stuff
that we wish should happen because the
game is so good against it we're not
saying the game is bad in any way no I
would've score positive impressions just
really just man like ya know for that
little bit extra exactly and there are
so many things that I think that I
really liked right like you know you're
talking about like being
isolated right and all you have are
these Holograms but when you are
interacting with the environment it's
it's really well done like there's the
one thing that took me was like oh I
really like that which remind me of so
many first-person kind of uh you know
object manipulation where it's like you
know you think of like Fallout right you
just pick all the stuff like a junket
like yeah the idea of putting something
back exactly where you picked it up I
was like yeah that works in the rooms
like that's so cool because it's like
polite you know I mean it's like
investigative works like I was learning
through people so but it's there's that
aspect I know there's a you know there's
a one area we're like you know there's
dartboard right like there's something
about I don't almost remind me of like
being or the movie moon right where it's
like what are you gonna do by yourself
to like occupy or satisfy your like
loneliness like you know they're gonna
they celebrate holidays obsolescence day
which is like an ironic holiday and
within the context of the game yeah and
like the dartboard has a picture of like
their company's CEO says I didn't notice
that the CEOs face yeah there's like
little things like that and I I agree
that looks like being able to put things
back head so like it conveyed so much
respect for the people that were there
like that their stuff is still here
they've you know you know that they've
been evacuated and just the fact that
like like I was going through somebody's
things and like there's like a really
touching note and totally the fact that
like I took a like a lid off of a box I
open the drawer I did all of this stuff
but then I could just carefully put the
lid back I don't everything back what if
you could have taken some of the things
that were most important to them all
that would've been so cool just like
deliver to them later well hold on I
don't know what happens later on no I
mean like that's not a spoiler I just
seen the beginning they're alive so if
you were able to go no no that's not at
all sorry I guess I guess that sounds
like a spoiler but it's not like the
idea that like you know that like
they've been evacuated it be cool if
like you could just take like a picture
or something there's yeah there's I
don't think I can't think of a game
where you could like do that you know II
mean like any kind of like object Good
Samaritan things yeah
neat about that it does make you you
kind of perform a little bit when you're
in like these scenes I like found myself
framing the seams like I see them yeah I
crouched down to like get a better view
like I was like really trying to like to
really absorb embrace that Keira felt
weird standing right next to a hologram
when they were talking on the phone was
like it's not the person but it's it's I
feel like I'm intruding on their space
yeah and yeah there's anything I could
say like that I thought when I was
playing I was like man like this is such
a cool feature as far as like being an
investigator that I want to see it in
other types of games like yeah I don't
know like off top my head like cyberpunk
if there's like you know you think about
what you're in is like you know senses
and you know the very which become kind
of rudimentary our follow the trail like
just the idea of like taking a time at a
scene and like rewinding and get
different angles yeah like you everyone
kind of had the same experience it's
like yeah like taking a knee and like
angle and yeah like that yeah the
picture is putting those back and
closing the door like a drawer like oh
yeah I really got a kick out of that
yeah I even started cleaning up I
started like ice there was like a cup on
the ground and I like 17 hours yeah so
you're full review is up on the site
video review on YouTube GameSpot you can
go check that out if you're watching
live now or after the fact on iTunes etc
do have to move on to switch gears
pretty heavily Wolfenstein to a game not
as much about you know characterization
actually like what's the first new order
was really good characterization out but
here you got BJ Blazkowicz you know you
start off in a wheelchair or maybe you
don't start off you're on you boat you
start from wheelchair you got to play
this section recently Kelly in a preview
event mm-hmm
damn you you play like everything oh
yeah I feel bad I feel like I been
talking a lot stop hogging the airwaves
not just kidding
yeah so people are excited bout this
game October 27 ps4 Xbox one PC
follow up what's a sudden 80s as opposed
to the first game 60 it's still sixties
okay he's been you find out very early
on in this level that he's been in bed
like crippled for five months on it's a
very direct continuation of new order
which which you were in like a coma
prior to when it started yes yeah and
after the prologue I just so I got to
play this section which was also at e3
but the coolest thing about this to me
is I mean the wheelchair stuff seems
like it would be super janky and I think
the one thing is getting over the door
frames in a u-boat would be a lot harder
in a wheelchair with one hand with one
hand it's like it's appropriately janky
like movement I thought more about and
the section is is really really fun you
can set traps it's great so the more I'm
looking at is are you because you have
one hand on the left tire is this am i
seeing a lot of like shimmying I guess
you could say like with like back and
forth I don't know it the minute you
said it felt great
or fudging the physics I think it's just
definitely fudging the physics but you
notice he like he'll move the wheel and
then there would be like a small break
and he'll have to get it again it's okay
it feel I mean like obviously it's not a
one-to-one what actually being in a
wheelchair bomb is like but it is cool
that it's it you still feel powerful
it's not like oh I feel helpless because
you're just like alright I'm gonna use
my machine gun the to [ __ ] up these
Nazis but like it's still it it's
disempowering enough that maybe it's an
interesting way to start a game I think
oh yeah before we move on from like
talking about mechanics uh Adam Ross and
on Twitter did ask how did the guns feel
and I think that's actually an important
question for this game because the what
was great about the first Wolfenstein
are sorry the reboot in 2014 was that
the guns felt very they were tough to
control there's a there wasn't a lot of
weight to him like a battlefield game or
a Killzone game but they're they are
kind of hard to control right there
these are kind of like rugged almost
like it kind of suits the games
personality of just like this really
really gritty thank you yeah watching
this shooting this gun it seems the same
thing you know it's in one hand it's all
over the place it's not like you're not
the Master Chief although bjs close but
it seems like they're kind of going for
that again which I'm glad to see ya
they're definitely unwieldy that's
another word I'm looking for what is
wrong
later on you can upgrade them and so
there's a second section I got to play
where we had like unlock points or
whatever it is upgrade points so that
helps you can get like a gun that's a
little easier to handle
but the mechanically is very similar so
I think if you liked the mechanics in
new order you can kind of know what to
expect going in night I think it's more
of a good thing like I don't think it's
a bad thing that it's similar but here
you can see some of these menus where
you can upgrade the weapons and I am a
sucker for a very aesthetically designed
menu so I liked these a lot like
schematics yeah these schematics are so
cool cool and there's like a lot of
customization here so I put a silencer
on my pistol which I ended up not I
wasn't very stealthy what can you still
kill like officers to stop in a lot
right yes yes I probably underused the I
mean you could even see like the bounces
like very like it's it's rugged and I
guess gritty which is not a word I like
to use very often but I think it fits
here the the one thing that's that's new
that we got to explore was dual wielding
which now I mean dual wielding isn't new
but you can dual wield two different
weapons mm-hmm which I think adds a
dimension of like okay I'm prepared for
whoever comes at me yeah but it was
really hard to switch with a controller
as playing with a Xbox controller
they had like separate weapon wheels for
each hand right yeah it's two weapon
wheels but it was a little finicky and I
think that might get cleaned up so I
just opted to snipe this is my gameplay
yeah I might get cleaned up this also
was like a super difficult level
according to everybody who played we all
struggled a lot with this so I'm sure
it'll get it is like a little rough
around the edges not in the gritty
Wolfenstein way but in a it's still in
the works way yeah that's interesting
because when I first played a new order
at e3 2014 before it came out it may be
2013 2014 at e3 but the game came out in
2014 and it was tough it didn't feel
balanced and then it came out it was
fantastic so I'm wondering what maybe
there's something about their
development cycle because a lot of
people were saying the same thing I
might just try to put this you know I
really difficult day can push the
difficulty in the hands of someone who's
never played it before like the reason
us as
yeah basically that's interesting that
is very likely I I mean this was I
played on like the base like the normal
difficulty and they added a lot of
difficulty levels too so this was like
third in a list of eight difficulties oh
really yeah I mean and and you're one of
the more experienced like shooter fans
in our office so I was watching your
footage like this does look really hard
yeah I was like I so I was proud of my
wheelchair section footage because that
was like a fully balanced level I didn't
die like I have a really clean game play
on that and this was just brutally hard
and I played new order on Xbox so I was
like oh yeah I'll just play the Xbox
controller is what I'm used to and I was
like oh man this is this is rough we
might were played he had the same thing
John Luke had the same thing where we
were like why do we keep dying I got
stuck in a horrible autosave loop so it
does it does feel like it was like
alright how come how far can we push
this a frustration on you yeah that
what's the name of that armor is the
Hebrew word I forget what it is but it's
that kind of like power armor you get em
hmm
it makes me uncomfortable now because
looks like grayscale from games yeah
that means it's just this like infection
that it looks like on yours yeah like
black scabs but I'm curious I'm also
curious just like how does it feel like
it's functioning as a sequel right it's
sticking to what made the its
predecessor good right but it's it's
making enough changes mechanically and
did you get a good sense like the
overall story please it's fitting yes so
we saw um like new order has those two
kind of timelines right we just we've
seen both of those characters in what we
played so gently' can I just assume that
it's going to be a continuation of
either timeline we're not clear on how
that will work yet but we kind of just
gues inferred by the characters that we
saw as a story I think like the one I
wrote about this for the embargo is I
think they're doing a really really good
job at fleshing out the alternate
history and I think this was in new
order as well but you can go around and
read articles and read you know
newspaper clippings and reviews of books
and look at photographs and people's
letters and all of that goes a long way
to develop like the world
they're building which is both pulpy and
serious you have you know like I mean
Nazis are not like light-hearted right
but they managed to make it not like the
most depressing thing ever
reminds me of the Yakuza games yeah
exactly and I think they they hit that
stride really well um you you walk
through Roswell and the first thing you
see when you arrive is two KKK members
walking past a Nazi officer and it's the
conversation they have is very
tongue-in-cheek there I mean they both
have these like horribly like cartoonish
southern accents their names are like
Jeb and Wyatt yeah this KKK guys here
yeah these plans men who are just
learning in full dress and they're like
really polite like sir sorry sir - a
Nigerian Nazis like I like your style
Americans are you going to the concert
and then he says something kind of
threatening to them in there so there's
a lot at work here but then you also
walk by a young couple who's like
practicing their German they're saying I
love you in German or like the the
mother and son you see and you saw at e3
in the the diner where she's telling him
like alright you really got to practice
your german he's like the Fuhrer is a
great artist or whatever it is and so
there's that dichotomy of people making
fun of Hitler for being a terrible
artist which he was and the the idea of
like she that kid has to learn German
now because of this and so I just really
really like that stuff and so I think
that's you know it's really expanding
upon that bringing the the game to
America is another thing so I'm excited
to see where they take it yes
interesting as far cry 5 is also using
kind of a small microcosm of a dystopian
America almost maybe not just a more
contemporary right yeah Stefon here that
that feels contemporary
even though it's set in the 60s I mean
there's just the the way things are
written are very tongue-in-cheek sort of
almost like their references to today
and so I think it's staying grounded in
that like like it's hard to explain I
think without you like you just walking
through it and exploring it but there's
like a review of a dystopian novel where
the Allies won the world war one the war
and it just says things that seem like
they're referencing America great again
I didn't want to take it there but yes
exactly and so I think they're they're
kind of keeping it keep in a
tongue-in-cheek with that side note but
every time you glance at the gas station
is this your gameplay I think there was
did you see those like vehicles there
though it was just a big wheel that they
sat on with chair in the middle oh that
reminds me like some from Star Wars or
something I don't know but yeah I like I
love their technology in these games oh
yeah absolutely and I think it's really
interesting because like of course like
the right which is going to have these
crazy technological developments by
nature of being the being who they are
yeah man and these scenes here these
like I mean they're almost just like set
pieces like this one namely it was one
that they've been showing off for a lot
right like this is the very much
inglorious basterds feel and Minh you
know it's clearly inspired by inglorious
basterds but this is something we're
just like this that's fine that's so fun
it's something they did the one in the
first game of the train with a Frau
Engel when you're picking like those
tarot cards almost not tarot cards like
fortune reading or she's just like doing
a psychological test on you is pretty
tense it's it's that balance between
like like genuine like fear and and and
making you know these villains scary at
the same time it's also like just funny
and light-hearted right like yeah those
bastards had this had all those same
scenes like that the first scene with
the in the farmhouse right like that was
just so terrifying yet light-hearted I
guess you could say unsettling
friendliness right I know that you're
evil right where is this going you're
manipulating is it my fear that's
reading into you or are you yeah or are
you manipulating me yes and this scene
is so good because he's being so
intimidating but he's just like slurping
down a strawberry milkshake the whole
time of course and it I get that vibe of
like the the counting the way Germans
count three versus Americans you know
that oh that you know that but that's
the second seen that movie English
bastards yeah yes like that's that's
driving the vibe again yeah where he's
like he's on to you right like oh
station six I don't I don't know about
that station you know and it's I just I
think they they they nailed the vibe
with this feeling doc I love how he
opens it up with one
and that's it seems really well like
animated and polished too and again the
characters and the voice acting like the
there's the cinematics mm-hmm
if you all area sawsan just a shout out
we have like a video of all the
cutscenes we have so far and like if you
want to check out just like how they are
giving depths these cutscenes the
cutscenes are like of a decent length
there's a lot going on I would
definitely recommend checking those out
cool
yeah I mean we have a lot more coverage
on the site in general I love the TV in
the back with BJ and the wanted so just
turned on well yeah the sign was also
their necks to the door but yeah so this
scheme also releases on October 27th
along with Super Mario Odyssey and
Assassin's Creed origins probably more
coverage leading up to it I'm really
excited for this I just replayed a new
order the new order recently and this
looks you know nothing but good so far
cool it's pretty show to do our giveaway
quick she was gonna probably tweet it if
she hasn't already she might be about to
it's a final fantasy 12 like limited
edition giveaway the zodiac Age
steelbook collector's edition for the
zodiac Age X judge Magisters bust set I
imagine those the Bad Dudes steelbook
and everything it's a big thing - yeah
as usual Shiva will be tweeting it if
you don't follow GameSpot on Twitter go
do so please
and then retweet that sweet we'll pick
you at random later in the week so there
you go that is our giveaway pretty dope
I haven't started that game yet but two
more apparently has been blasting
through it and he keeps telling me to
play it either play to Final Fantasy
before yeah I know a psycho Wolff 15 and
tactics oh no I started well I started
tactics but I haven't like people did
but I think pedestrian was the word you
used no I don't never describe anything
I'm all for the common folk for the
pedestrians I wouldn't use that as a
derogatory term yeah as usual thank you
for joining YouTube twitch GameSpot
gentle ook sake Eric Tay
Richard Lee in the back thank you for
producing the show as always and we will
be back next Wednesday at 11:00 a.m.
we'll see you then
tomorrow's Triforce